good afternoon everybody this is laura
mcdermott from cornell cooperative
extension i'm talking i just want to
welcome you to the
northeast sayre professional development
project
soil management and berry crops as a
model for management education
this is the 11th in a series of 12
in-depth berry crop nutrition and soil
management trainings
and
we are really happy to have you here
as you log on if you would please just
know in the chat box where you are
from and what you work with that would
really help our speaker who is from the
university of florida
get a better idea of who is in the
audience
i expect that we'll have a few more
people log on but in the meantime i'm
going to just show you
around in case you have not been here
before i want to make sure that you're
custom and familiar with the adobe
classroom
the web links box at the lower left hand
corner is where you can download you can
be linked directly to the websites that
are listed the webinar archives and
northeast sayre are listed there
then in the lower right hand corner are
the files
that we would be very uh happy to have
those of you who have not filled out
the educator northeast sayre educator
pretest and the northeast sayre
demographics questionnaire both of these
are very important for the grant
information so we encourage you to
do that and send that back to kathy
heidenreich
but let's just allow just a few more
moments for people to log on and then
i'm going to go into the second part of
the training but just let me give them
another minute or so to make sure that
everybody's logged on
i do want to draw your attention
to the fact that we're looking for a
little bit of input and at the very
bottom of the notes pod if you scroll
down
kathy has stated that there's
if there's any topics or issues related
to berry crop soil and nutrient
management
that have not yet been addressed
next week on march
what is that march 6th excuse me march
9th
um that is the last webinar for this
series that'll be at two o'clock p.m and
dr harold vanessa will be leading that
but part of that will be to address any
remaining questions that might exist
so i think at this point let's um
let's move into the second portion of
the
webinar
and i'd like to introduce to you our
invited speaker
dr santos
dr belinsky santos is an assistant
professor of horticulture with the
university of florida and ifas
he conducts research on strawberry
tomato bell pepper and increasingly high
bush blueberry
he works out of the um
sugar i should have read from the other
side i think it's the research station
the golf research station
um
at ifas and he works specifically with
fertilizer irrigation protected
agriculture
with those remaining crops and
increasingly blueberries
and that's the gulf coast research and
extension
center experiment center so thank you
very much uh dr dr santos so sorry about
kind of get that introduction a little
bit bobbled but
i'm going to let you take it from here
and people will be continually logging
on i think that dr santos had asked
we spoke about this earlier if you could
hold your questions
till the end or if you want to type them
in go ahead but we'll we'll take all the
questions at the very end of the
presentation
so thanks very much and we'll get
started
well thank you laura i really appreciate
the opportunity to be here today and
talk to a very diverse group of
colleagues uh both in research and
extension i really appreciate that and
also appreciate the fact that i'm 80
degrees here in florida where it's kind
of cold up there
so
if you guys don't fall asleep i'm gonna
try the best
to try to keep your attention towards
this next uh few minutes
uh as laura mentioned part of my
responsibilities at the university of
florida are to
direct the
vegetables and small fruit horticultural
program that focuses on
fertilization water management protected
ag and cultural practices for
most of our target crops that include
tomatoes peppers strawberries
blueberries and mosquito carbonates
today
we are going to be talking mostly about
strawberries
and how uh the fertigation techniques
and
some of the hydroponics have been
experimented here in florida and abroad
also because uh part of the activities
that we conduct
uh
both research and extension uh no are
not only in florida but also in
california spain argentina chile and
other parts of the world where we have
all the research being conducted right
now
so
with uh with that said we are going to
be focusing today on three basic aspects
and the fertigation by itself uh we're
gonna be talking about a little bit of
the concepts of this
uh we're gonna be trying to be really
really broad in this knowing that
previous speakers probably touch
a lot of the aspects of the nutrition
and fertilization
uh later we're gonna go to the rate
determination which is sometimes one of
the most important aspects and what
relates to this when it comes to
fertigation and fertilization of
strawberries in general and also the
third touch aspect is going to be
touching on
the some of the diagnostic tools we are
using right now i've been asked to
look into not only the way that we
produce strawberries which is along with
california very different to the rest of
the country
we deal with strawberries as an annual
crop
we don't have a second crop or the third
crop like in some cases we have in in
the north
uh but also some of the
emergent technologies that some growers
are using not only here bring other
parts of the world when it comes to
fertigation and try to determine the
best way the the best way the crops can
perform
so we think into all the subjects you're
gonna be seeing that we have certain
aspects that we're gonna be touching
hopefully we're going to be
kind of thorough about it and give
practical examples of what each one of
these aspects mean and what we've been
doing in florida with regard to each one
of them
so when we look at fertigation
uh
we we cannot separate the nutrition
aspect from the irrigation practices
and we always tell everybody that if
there is one thing that we when we talk
about fertilization in general is that
there are not
uh certain recipes that need to be
followed uh every situation is gonna be
different
and
uh one thing that you're gonna see today
is that we are not going to give
specific recommendations blanket
recommendations for everybody to do
fertigation
as opposed to touching the principles
that
take you to those recommendations and
for you to adjust to your own programs
so when we we call fertigation in the
process by which we apply fertilizers
through the irrigation system
and
by doing that
we can use two types of specific
specific fertilizers the ones that are
ready to use
in a liquid matrix uh which is the most
common method that is used by the
strawberry growers here in florida and
in in in parts of california and also we
have the hydro soluble salts these are
solid uh salts uh just diluted in water
that you similar to the ones that you
buy
sometimes in the in the hardware stores
that you go by salt and just dissolve it
and apply it
both of them have
pros and cons obviously when you
carrying a big liquid matrix or
fertilizer they charge you a lot more
for the
for the cost of taking the fertilizer to
you uh because they're carrying a lot of
water with them however these are
fashion-made formulas that you they're
tailored to your specific needs
and you just apply the formula you don't
have to worry about usually about the
formula precipitating to the bottom of
the tank unless that is really cold
uh and you know exactly what you're
applying
the problem with the salts when they are
hydrosoluble in contrast with that is
that usually people the the more that
you handle this the more rain the
uh opportunity for error for human error
that you're gonna find
because one day somebody's making the
mixes that in a week somebody
is going to be doing it
and there might be differences on the
type on the fertilizer you you're really
applying in the field
however we
regardless of the formula that you use
no fertilization program is going to be
ever efficient
if a poor irrigation program is in place
and this is something that we've been
formulating to our growers this second
aspect is extremely important
uh
strawberry growers in florida are very
efficient handling the water during the
season
and that
translates into good use
of
the fertilizer that is applied during
that period
now
we know and when we talk to our growers
i usually this process is not a simple
process that
that they can do
uh on their own without the education
that we carry to them
and one of the principles that we uh
tell them all the time
is that nutrients
only move as far as the water moves
those nutrients so they have to be clear
about that and that's that's why a lot
of strawberry growers are very very
successful in that regard however many
of you might be wondering you know how
they handle fertilization
in a situation like they do in florida
well
soil this is the type of soil that we
have
it's
very sandy extremely sandy is the
closest that you're gonna find to a
beach without sodium in it
uh and that makes it extremely
challenging and in fact somebody asked
me the other day
how we were able to do this and i just
tell them that we take a lot of the
hydroponic principles to produce
strawberries here because it's the
closest to the hydroponic system that
you're going to find in real life
when you got this deep sands
infiltration really quickly
and that's challenging to us
because when you have a soil like this
when growers apply water and have a crop
like strawberries that we grow
in a annual health system like this when
usually we establish the strawberries
with sprinklers irrigation protect the
berries also with sprinklers and have
one or two
drip tapes like the ones that you see
here at the bottom of this
slide in each one of the beds
it creates an opportunity to
apply fertilizers in a very efficient
way but at the same time it's a
challenge it's challenging because you
can have have a high risk
of leaching fertilizer and if you don't
believe me that
i'm just gonna leave you with this
picture when this is a cross cross
section of a bed
uh sandy bed like we have here in
florida
and the picture on top represents
uh
watering that bed with one drip tape for
one hour that's how quickly the water
moves down without moving further out on
the sides
and that's when we
have to
challenge ourselves to keep those
nutrients within that root zone and
making sure that nobody
waters excessively so they can be
efficient when they apply fertilizers
the pictures the pic the second picture
at the bottom of the slide
represents beds with two drip tapes and
in both cases this is one hour of
irrigation
and the top uh
in that case we were able to achieve
31 percent coverage of the bed of the
area of the bed whereas with two drip
tapes you get barely 67 that means
two-thirds of the bed have been arbiting
water when when you have one-third of
the bed that hasn't been
touched by water so you have to be sure
that you know only put the right rate of
fertilizer but also the placement of the
fertilizer along with the irrigation
program has to be efficient for us to
make sure that we make
uh we may make the best use possible of
the
resources that are put out there in the
field for producing strawberries
now
going back a little bit to the
principles that we
follow here in florida particularly
we usually tell our growers that they
shouldn't be irrigating for more than an
hour
and the reason is that those pictures
are you just saw after an hour of
irrigation you're probably dumping
uh most of your fertilizer into the
aquifers
uh because it just leaks down
also another important thing
that we tell our growers is that they
should have monitoring equipment
to make sure that they monitor how much
water they have in the beds and knowing
when to apply and when to not to apply
later on we're going to see some
pictures of the type of equipment
that they're being there it's been used
right now to make sure that the water is
used appropriately
also
we extensively
educate our growers on on knowing
uh the kind of soil that they have
they have to calibrate the soil they
have to know what the field capacity is
because believe it or not all the sands
are not equal
there are some sandy areas here that are
very fast very fine sand
that you get the field capacity when the
soil is barely in 12 percent
whereas there are other areas when you
have a heavier type of sand that work
field capacity is around 18
so they need to know exactly what kind
of soil they have and even within the
same farm
knowing the pockets of soils that they
might have and i'm gonna provide more
lead details later on
on the broad diagnostic
of farms and how growers can section the
farm uh depending on what kind of soil
they have
the whole objective of all this
obviously is to keep the water and the
rooting zone and to do that
we want to make sure that our growers at
least have
one of these two if not both pieces of
equipment
that allow them
to monitor water in the soil
for that
we have two basic basic pieces of
equipment
potentiometers which are the traditional
uh piece of equipment that measures
water tension in the soil they have very
decent accuracy even though we are
disputing this more and more because
sometimes in the middle range
of tensions you might not have an
accuracy that that will tell you exactly
how much water you should put out there
the disadvantage is that you have to use
one unit per location that you're going
to be collecting data and making sure
that
that
uh
unit is there and it's clean that's it's
not collecting algae and anything like
that extremely easy to use and very
inexpensive
however the other pieces of equipment
like what you see on the right here in
the which is called a time domain
reflectometer
uh which is relatively expensive one of
these units can go anywhere from 500 to
thousands of dollars
uh he has
this handheld unit that gives you an
instant reading of soil volumetric water
and has these prongs that go into the
soil that can be calibrated at different
depths
and you it can tell you instantly the
the volume of water that you have in the
soil therefore if you know that your
soil fill capacity is at 15 percent uh
at six inches deep you immediately get
everything to tell you that that's what
you have over there
uh another advantage of this unit is you
can buy one unit or two units for the
whole farm you can have a farm manager
just going around and just collecting
the
the
volume of water in the soil uh the
beginning of the cycles or before the
beginning of the irrigation cycles it's
very easy to use however the downsize is
they could be a little bit unaffordable
for some people there are other units
that are extremely more complicated that
are based on the same
principle or similar principles uh but i
think that that escapes the scope of
what we're trying to do today we're not
trying to do a seminar on how to monitor
water but rather to use practical tools
to monitor water and in a situation when
growers might be struggling to make a
profit
so
uh usually when we're going to into also
in farms we are trying to make growers
aware of the necessity of knowing what
kind of cultivars they have
one thing that we found
is that uh
cultivars might respond totally
different to the same fertilization and
irrigation programs
and obviously varieties that have been
bred in florida would respond different
than varieties that have been bred in
california just basically because
they've been bred in totally different
environments so the selection pressure
would be different and the situation of
the california soils would be different
to ours and that would be true for a lot
of varieties that are bred in other
regions too
so we've been trying to
develop tools that allow us to
tailor different formulas for different
varieties and we're going to talk about
that a little bit later
now
when it comes to the second part of the
fertigation
soil versus soil sculpture i realize
that the vast majority of strawberries
in the u.s are grown on the soil
however there is a
increased
movement of people going to protect the
culture and going into soils culture
within those structures and that
requires also for us to provide
knowledge to that increasing group
both for the traditional con a
market of strawberries and also the
organic market of strawberries
but for that we just have to make sure
that we know the physical and chemical
properties of our soils if you're doing
soils
field capacity as i mentioned wilton
point texture structure is as important
as uh all the chemical properties such
as
organic matter content ph nutrient
content salinity and carrion exchange
capacity we have to make sure that our
growers understand that that's extremely
important
to adjust those fertilization programs
when it comes to soilless culture
uh so you got three different categories
of soils that you're gonna find
you got the solid substrates
uh
that which we're gonna talk a little bit
in the in the next slide we got the pure
hydroponics that are the plants used in
the liquid matrix of solution
uh
nutritional solution and also you got
something new that is called relatively
new that is called aeroponics when the
plant in the plant roots are in the air
and you get the constant mist of water
with nutrients that are spray into it
obviously of all this the solid
substrates is the most common and the
most used and only here in the us and
other parts of the world
now when talking about soilless media
uh the basic principle is that we are
just replacing the natural soil
with a lot of these materials
uh however many of them are naturally
deficient on a lot of nutrients you got
you you can you can pick whatever
soilless media is out there and you're
always going to find efficiencies
of certain nutrients and that's when
they know how
comes into play you need to know what
kind of media you have
uh but we know that a soy good soils
media should provide good food support
good nutrient water retention allow gas
gas exchange and also be a pest-free
environment because it's a way for us to
get away from the fumigation of the soil
and and
other problems that we may have
now
when it comes to mineral origin media
you got pearlite vermiculite sand and
rock wool which are very common out
there and in the organic
side you got all from vegetable or
animal origin you got coconut core peat
pine bark compost different types of
compost all kind of compost out there
and also rice holes that are usually
either used as they are or burnt
uh
you look at a lot of these materials and
as i mentioned as i put in a slide
before not necessarily the cheapest is
the best
uh it all depends on what kind of needs
you have uh what kind of irrigation
fertilization program and equipment you
might have in the farm if you have a an
equipment that you can only fertilize
once per day you might want to make sure
that your soil is media adjust to that
type of regime
otherwise you're gonna may be running in
trouble here in florida we have some
specific examples of
soils and containers that are being used
for
strawberry production this is a grower
here in florida when we get strawberries
growing troughs and those troughs are
filled with pine bark
all of this with drip tape and
fertigation
also bags almost very close to the soil
over
this uh concrete blocks
when when we fill the bags with pine
bark
also you got all the growers that have
bags that are filled with coconut core
usually these bags are pre-mixed and
bring the coconut core and usually it's
important from asia
and
finally you have also growers that might
be
have been struggling in the past and
have tables like this
and
they might be reusing those tables for
something else like people that had
nurseries before and we've been
converting so these people to uh
producing strawberries on top of the
tables with substrate
also other people have been looking into
vertical production with these vertical
systems they
they they might save a lot of space
however usually when you run into these
lower levels
the the light quality and intensity is a
problem and strawberries might not
flower too well down there
however from the first two three four
five levels depending on where you are
and the type of plastic cover that you
have on top you might be very successful
producing the crop
now moving on when we look at the
injection equipment
for fertilizers you usually are talking
about uh two or three classical pieces
of equipment
that are uh convenient and some of them
are very cheap so it has pros and cons
uh with regard to one and one to the
other
the first uh piece of equipment that i
want to show you
is uh
what they call the eventually suck uh
suction uh injector this is a very
simple
uh
system however the problem is that when
you have a system like this
you as the pressure
of the line of the water line changes
you might be changing
the pressure and the injection
of this uh each one of these
ventries into the line which is going to
end giving you a very variable
fertilizer rate that you're going to be
applying
so
this is a very simple method very
inexpensive for a lot of growers but
they require to monitor the injection of
each fertilizer more efficiently that
they would do with a system like this
this is uh what usually the very
constant
injection they could be both hydraulic
like the one on the left or they could
be electric like the one on the right
and there is a company that is called
dosatron that's where we're taking the
name from uh no endorsement intended
here uh
but these systems
inject a very constant rate uh at a very
broad range of pressure water pressure
so if you go from 20 psi to 10 psi
you're going to continue injecting the
same a concentration of fertilizer into
the stream which is going to allow you
to have the same rate it's just that the
irrigation and the fertigation process
is gonna last longer if the pressure
drops
so
for those of you who might uh
uh
have plenty of money to go into it uh
especially growers
there are some computerized consoles
that do all this for you and you you
don't have to mess around a lot with
this system because they adjust
the fertilization throughout the season
by themselves you just have a program
that goes into but this these are a lot
more expensive that all those methods
and one thing that we want to make sure
is uh and take home message is that more
expensive not necessarily means better
it depends also how you
set up your system and how committed you
are to be precise in terms of the
fertilization that you're going to be
applying
in many cases when you get hydro-soluble
fertilizer fertilizers you get a
multi-tank injection point when you get
one tank for every type of fertilizer
that you're going to be applying out
there
for example in this tank in the left in
this case you got the acids like
phosphoric acid is being injected
through that tank and this one you got
micronutrients
that are being injected in other cases
you've got phosphates and sulfates and
in the other one you have nitrates the
idea for this is that you don't mix a
lot of these fertilizers because
they can precipitate to the bottom
so
if you have a hydrosoluble fertilizer
you need to separate them and make sure
that you inject inject the right
proportion
of all of them this is a very common
system that is used in greenhouses all
over the world when salts are added to
water instead of ready to use
liquid solutions like we use in the open
field in florida and many parts of
california
so
moving on to rate determination
which is the second part of our our
conversation today uh you're gonna see a
lot of now practical examples of how we
calculate rates for strawberry
production in florida i just want to put
this slide here so you are refreshing to
you what the micro micronutrients are
and a lot of these formulas sometimes
might not have all the micronutrients
and they need to be supplemented
depending on the soil needs that you
have
so but even more important even as
important as uh rate determination
also we need to make sure that we know
the sources that place the placement of
the fertilizer
and the timing when all this is going to
be done
and to make sure
that we
sometimes in some cases or some
micronutrients like for example zinc or
iron or sulfur
we use blanket recommendations because
sometimes we don't have specific
calibrated uh
tests that will tell you exactly how
much we need an assist in that place or
you might have a piece of land that is
brand new that nobody has done any
any strawberries in that part of the the
state and you may need to do use blanket
recommendations while you calibrate the
system
in any ways when you are determining the
the specific rate of application you
have to make sure that you take into
account the crop requirement the
leaching the losses through
volatilization and chemical and
biological immobilization in the soil
and that's going to give you a rough
application rate that you're going to be
applying all these tools we take it into
account when determining
uh
the best rate for producing uh for
applying and fertilizing and producing
strawberries in our state
now at the same time we say that we
mentioned earlier that the different
cultivars
uh with different growing rates and
plant architecture is going to play a
major role in how much fertilizer you
put out there
so we focus a lot of our attention here
in florida to looking at pre-planned and
early nmp fertilization as well as uh um
at the adjustments during the season of
nitrogen and potassium throughout the
the production cycle
to
give you a clear picture of what we do
in that regard
we concentrate a lot on nitrogen and
potassium because these two are the most
used nutrients or the most
applied nutrients in our situation
nitrogen is you should apply 100 through
the drip tapes
sometimes some people might apply a
little bit and pre-plant
six years ago this was around sixty
percent of the acreage
right now
uh we are only below twenty percent of
the acreage of people that apply
pre-plant nitrogen uh supplement that
with trip later on the usually the rates
were between 20 and 50 pounds per acre
of nitrogen that were applied before the
drip tapes were in
in the case of potassium 100 is
delivered through the drip tapes
a lot of this has been changing in the
recent years because of the
environmental concerns that we have in
terms of nitrate moving into the
groundwaters
and
also implementing best management
practices for the crop
however there is not a single best
management practice better than rising
prices of fertilizer
and sometimes i say that in a way that
sounds sarcastic but that has
created
a more conscience
throughout growers of how to use
fertilizer more efficiently because the
prices have been going up uh in the year
2000 one tonne of fertilizer was below
200 dollars an acre the 200 a ton
and right now the fertilizers are above
500
and that has created a conscience of we
need to be more efficient applying
fertilizer
uh for
strawberry fertilization
a common very common fertilization
program here in florida is using one to
one and a half pounds of nitrogen per
acre per day
which is going to add up to around 150
to 175
pounds per acre per season remember our
season starts in october and we are done
at the beginning of march it's a very
short season because our market
is
the winter market and after that other
states take over the production in the
state and we become really hot to
produce strawberries so in that short
season we apply
usually between 150 175 pounds per acre
potassium is a little higher because
people have the perception that apply
more potassium at the end is gonna
increase fruit quality
uh which we're gonna try to
illustrate you uh on that regard in the
next slides
and also we are more conscious not right
now about looking at phosphorus in the
early stages of production
now
when it comes to using starter
fertilizer for applying nitrogen we've
conducted research in the past
that where we compare
uh the up no application of pre-planned
fertilizer versus the application of 50
pounds per acre of pre-plant nitrogen
using ammonium nitrate
as the source
and what we found
in that research consistently over time
is that
there was no significant difference
across the board
in any of the months when we
compared the production
of strawberries by not using starter
fertilizer or using starter fertilizer
at the beginning and this was done over
a period of three years
and this this is important because it
means
not only that the growers might be
saving around 17 to 20 bucks an acre on
the application plus the labor and
everything else but also
it's 50 pounds per acre and you multiply
that by 10 000 acres that's a tremendous
amount of fertilizer i was just sitting
there and doing absolutely nothing
for the crop
so
after that you know a lot of growers
were moving out of the business of
applying pre-plant nitrogen uh to the
crop and what they did is that they
started applying
connecting the drip tape as early as
possible to the crop and started
injecting
uh
nitrogen fertilizer as soon
as the plant was on the ground and they
did that for the first 10 days well we
also conducted research looking at this
but this time we made it a little bit
more complicated and we took two
different varieties
two varieties are standards for us it's
a florida strawberry festival which is
the most grown variety here in florida
and that is the red line and floyd
radiance that is the blue line
and we found is that these two varieties
that had two totally different
architectures react totally different to
that initial fertilizer rate that you're
putting out there uh in this case we
compare zero
zero point five
one and one and a half pounds per acre
per day in those two varieties for the
first 10 days after transplant we
injected that amount and we collected
the early yields of the varieties and
what we found is obviously with zero
there was no difference but there were
two totally different patterns as you
increase to 0.5
pounds per acre
you can see here that strawberry
festival continues increasing its early
yield as you move to one pound and
stabilizes after that whereas with
florida radiance the maximum yield was
obtained with 0.5 pounds those that
apply more than that there were no
significant differences
from that
obtaining at 0.5 pounds per acre
that is giving us more confirmation that
we need to design
uh
more tailor-made formulas for specific
cultivars and taking into account that
many growers apply as much as one and
one and a half pounds per acre across
the board for all the varieties
now we have to come up with ways to
differentiate across the cultivars and
part of the research that we've
conducted
had a lot to do with that and that's
what you see right there we look at two
other two varieties and then we start to
apply nitrogen throughout the season
which is different what you just saw
what you just saw previously was
nitrogen at the beginning starting in
the season and
uh we started looking at nitrogen
throughout the season now uh in two
different varieties and i have to make a
a
a note here that this is
regardless of the source we didn't find
any significant differences if we were
using uh calcium nitrate and other
nitrogen sources we were getting similar
responses as you're gonna see in a
second
uh what we found again is that there are
different responses across cultivars
regardless of the source of the
fertilizer that you're using and some
varieties like this blue line
winter dawn which is a very small plant
all it requires is three quarters of a
pound of nitrogen per acre per day
whereas a big variety like strawberry
festival needs
to get at least to 1.25 pounds per acre
per day
to
maximize early yields
uh when when we look at that we say okay
what about if we start comparing this to
a newer variety like florida radiance
and we did the similar study when we
were looking at that
and
we found that again we had two very
similar two very different patterns and
the two varieties radiance and festival
when
uh
radiance was maximizing at zero point
seventy five three quarters of a pound
and festival was getting the maximum at
125.
so that's giving us extra confirmation
what is even more important that extra
half pound per acre per day if you were
applying it in radians without needing
it it might mean 60 pounds per acre per
season that's a tremendous investment
that you don't need
when you're
producing florida ratings
so
what about
nitrogen and potassium ratios during the
season we've been told and led to
believe that by switching potassium
towards the end in strawberries it's a
good thing to increase increased fruit
quality
well
we've been doing studies when we are
looking at the traditional grower
practice that is
uh applying
a formula like six zero four or seven
zero four during the season until
mid-december and switching later to a
heavy potassium formula like four zero
six or four zero eight towards the end
supposedly to improve quality
well
research has been conducted in that
regard and what we found out
consistently is a plant diameter when
you go in different ratios one to one
one to twenty one to one twenty five and
one to one and a half nitrogen to
potassium
there were no significant differences
across the board
however when we move to total
fruit weight of the plants there was the
same pattern that was occurring with
plant diameter when there were no
differences uh among all the ratios that
were used
the same occur
when we look into the
the soluble solid content or the bricks
of the fruit
there were no differences of the ratios
uh remember that when i'm talking the
ratios here uh growers tend to switch to
one
to one and a half pounds
during the sea during the end of the
season to increase quality
well that wasn't needed in any of the
three varieties that we tested
consistently in the last two years here
so
there goes the myth that potassium
heavy at the at the end
increases the quality and the a total
fruit number and weight
what we did find and this was expected
were differences across the cultivars
and that was expected
so
when it comes to changing nitrogen and
potassium during the season we can
conclude that
uh
that we can use the same
fertilizer rate to throughout the season
provided that you're providing the
correct
rate from the beginning and the plan has
developed a very good routing system to
go down there and get the fertilizer you
already have been applying in the beds
and you're keeping all those nutrients
without the root zone
now
uh also we are looking into making sure
that we adjust the practices for
specific growers and that
growers design programs that make sense
for the needs now how do we design these
programs uh in the sense and how we
monitor all this throughout the season
obviously
the diagnosis diagnostic tools are going
to be a tremendous help for us
and yeah i know a lot of the
uh
visual assessment has been done during
the season and nothing beats you on eyes
but the problem is that usually when you
see the fissions this is kind of late
it's usually it has taken a toll on the
crop and you see a situation like like
in this picture
on the right
you got a severe deficiency here and
and you want to make sure that you get
to the plant before the leaves turn this
yellow
obviously zone deficiencies cannot be
seen at plain sight
and
we need to monitor
nutrients throughout the season we
usually tell our growers that
there are several tools out there
that they need to make sure that they
have and no specific tool
is uh
is going to help you
to
do a one fits all type of diagnostic
sometimes you need you need
you want all eyes out there looking at
the field also you need also to do
probably some kind of colorimetric test
at the same time you might do the foliar
test of uh to the plants
uh in the past the imperial up has been
used uh there are
several con there are severe
contradictions out there on
when is the right time to use a patio
sap test and whether this is a really
valuable tool
to measure deficiencies in plant because
some people argue that when you have
high concentrations in the patio
periods act as reservoirs for
nutrients and not necessarily means what
is going through the vascular tissue to
the leaves
so that that's one thing that keep an
eye on that not only to use periosteum
as a only test other people
also look at
colorimetric measurements to determine
the greenness of the leaves especially
if looking for
nitrogen magnesium iron deficiencies
and they use this pad meter which
measures the greenness of the leaves
and
those are just two of the most common
tools that are used out there
however
when you look at the
composition
of nutritional composition of the leaves
usually nothing beats a good leaf
analysis the downside of this is that
obviously by the time you collect the
samples and send it to the lab you get
results back
several days might go by
and that's why
the mo the the proactive approach of
making sure that your solutions
are accurate that you have the right ph
that you have the right electric
electrical conductivity of the solution
which by the way we haven't touched a
lot
but usually you get certain targets like
for the ph of the solution you don't
want to to go above 7.6 or or even to 8
nor lower than 6.2
to make sure that you have the right
solution out there it's also going to
depend on what kind of media you have if
you're growing in the soil or if you're
going in the media that captures or
retains a lot of those nutrients that
might give you more leeway in terms of
what kind of solution you might want to
apply out there
at the same time
the electrical conductivity of the
solution you don't want it to be too
high and i know that's particularly a
pro a problem in places when
you have very high ec of the water for
example here in florida in our station
our water is 7.0 0.7 decisions per meter
uh
the electrical conductivity of our
solution so when we apply fertilizer we
usually don't want to go above two
because strawberries are extremely
sensitive to any solution that is
applied to them consistently above two
decisions per meter so you want to make
sure that you keep a balance and that's
going to have a direct influence and
what frequency of fertilization you're
going to use if for if to obtain
the given fertilizer rate that you want
it's going to take that solution above 2
then you're probably better off lowering
the concentration of your solution and
applying the applying it more frequently
so all those are aspects that we work
with growers to make sure that they have
the right
program in place so they don't go
overboard and start seeing salinity uh
problems and
uh ph uh
the
ph disorders and the soil uh that i'm
gonna i'm gonna start
showing in the plants some of these
problems and also blocking the
absorption of certain nutrients
nevertheless we have a sufficiency range
for strawberries that
our university has put together in our
production handbook and we get certain
uh guidelines
no no written stone but certain
guidelines and how much nitrogen
phosphorus potassium calcium magnesium
sulfur iron manganese zinc boron copper
and molybdenum
the plant needs uh in a dry way basis
when when it comes to
adequate range of fertilization all this
is available either through our
website here my program or
the extension website of the university
that is free of charge
it could be accessed from anywhere if
anybody has a question about later on i
would like that table to get to you you
can either get a copy of the
presentation or to access the website
and i will be happy to direct you to the
right right spot
below that table we have another table
as i mentioned earlier we use all these
measurements all these diagnostic tools
to complement each other
you got a table that also shows show you
the perceived sufficiency ranges for our
conditions for nitrate nitrogen in the
periods and also for potassium uh in the
in the leaves so all that is available
at the same time and both tables are
together like that
so
uh we just want to make sure that we
design the right programs for our
growers now towards the end and we are
in the last few slides here uh we want
to concentrate all also in what it's out
there
now
i know a lot of people use area
photographs as a tool to diagnose
symptoms and this is extensively used in
agronomic crops
when people
corn
soybean and all the crops out there and
it's a tool that has been used more
increasingly
more in vegetables now especially when
this extent growing extended
areas
uh people are using strong more actively
nitrification inhibitors uh just to slow
down uh the process of conversion from
from
nh4 to
nitrate
uh and also
more and more people are using crop crop
refractants
measurements that is just a
sophisticated method to determine uh the
colors of the planet and what is
reflecting from the plants and i know
some fellow scientists have been working
actively in this
uh and i i wouldn't be surprised in the
next few years this method takes uh
is used a lot more extensively in the us
one of the methods that has been used
here in florida especially for people
who have large
very large
strawberry areas talking
about 100 acres
is using the aerial infrared photographs
as you can see in this picture it gives
you a good idea of what the high
uh vigor areas and you feel are and what
the low areas are and usually that's
tied up
to
the
the specific properties of the soil or
specific practices
uh
of that soil for example in this
specific case you're gonna you're gonna
see
the areas in green that represent the
low vigor areas of that field and
reading a little bit of the narrative
for this picture those were areas
that were both either poor fumigated or
have very
limiting drainage situations in it
and this is a tool that has been used
more actively now to
know what you have in the field and make
sure that you make adjustments either on
that season or for next season
to do amendments uh pinpointed to
specific blocks of land of the field as
you can see here you got in the left
side of this picture you got nine
different fields all of them with very
different uh vigor with the same variety
and that allows that grower to
to say okay this is a very low spot this
is a very high spot or this is a spot
that has higher organic matter than the
other and that allows you to make
adjustments
now
towards the end now
we are looking more increasingly into
uh looking at the effects of
nutrients and growth and quality
not only the traditional nitrogen and
potassium but also i mentioned that
we've been focusing even more on
phosphorus now uh the reason is because
even our soils have a lot of phosphorus
uh available
uh sometimes we see phosphorus uh
addition
increasing the quality of the of the
plant
and then that's probably because
when the young transplant is putting in
the beds you don't have enough
phosphorus around the root zone for the
new roots to absorb at the given time
so you might have phosphorus in the
environment but might not have it where
you want it
so we we are working on that too the
other thing that we're doing
uh is working actively on management of
soil sculpture
to make sure that growers have what they
need
and it's every specific
soilless
medium
has specific characteristics
and
we want to make sure that we pinpoint to
them what are the practices that they
need
for a specific conditions that they
might have in the farm
if you
get any further questions are beyond the
seminar
uh i'm putting my email there
so anybody can feel free to
expand over this and discuss this a
little bit further or if any other
subject was left out
i will be more than happy to answer your
question just allow me a couple days for
it because i keep traveling all over the
world so sometimes i might not even
be in the country when i might be
answering some of the questions but i
will be happy to do it because this kind
of exchange
with
people from other states colleagues
researchers and extensionists is what
really what enriches the process of uh
gaining knowledge and generating
technologies for
our growers and all the growers in the
us
with that i'm going to leave it for
questions and i appreciate your
attention today and your
patience with all this uh
presentation
dr santos thank you so much um this is
laura speaking and we do have a couple
of questions that people have typed in i
imagine there's a few other questions
out there so those of you in the
audience go ahead and if you have them
please type them in i have a few
but first
jeff miller asks whether or not you've
compared the use of calcium nitrate with
urea or ammonium sources of nitrogen
for trickle solutions
well that's a great question uh as i
mentioned before uh we've compared those
sources and
uh talking about calcium nitrate and
ammonium sources
and we have found no significant
differences in the way that it's used
for strawberries now if we were talking
about all the crops it might make a
whole lot of a difference especially
blueberries that we know that respond a
lot better to
uh
no3 sources
than rather than ammoniacal sources
but in the case of our strawberries and
the way that growers handle it
uh and the rates that we use we haven't
found any significant differences across
the board
all right thank you
and the beginning portion of you started
talking about ratios of n2k where k was
less than a one to one ratio you were
talking i think more about k being a
higher ratio but can you
uh mention if you check those ratios
where k was actually less
yes we have ma we have checked those
ratios before and we decided to leave
that out of the research because in
preliminary studies we found out that
those ratios that could respond to less
than one
pound per acre per day of potassium
really start taking a toll on the plants
so
usually from the condition that the
growers have here in california growers
tend to over apply fertilizer not to
under apply
and
but by looking at those ratios of
preliminary stuff research that we
conducted told us that yes we didn't
need to go lower than that but rather to
compare one one and a quarter and one
and a half pounds of potassium during
the season which is the most common
practice for those growers here
okay and then we have one more question
and i think you mentioned that the goal
for the ph of your solution would be a
6.2 of a low and then
the maximum would be somewhere between
7.6 and 8.0
that's correct
and those are the extremes and you try
to have a
a nutritional solution that doesn't go
below 6.5 and doesn't go higher than 7.3
or something like that if you have to
deal for a short time with a solution
that is 7678 it's not the end of the
world but that tends to accumulate over
time
so
for a given point in time when you're
applying that you might might be fine
especially if the plans are big and
vigorous they can take it really well
however you try to stay close to
neutrality as much as possible
okay wonderful
we have another question